escribir una desigualdad que se ajuste a
la gráfica que se muestra abajo así que
no se han dibujado una línea en rojo y
la desigualdad incluye esta línea porque
está en rojo y no en una digamos línea
punteada así que todo lo que tenemos que
hacer es hallar el área de arriba con
una que sea mayor o igual a esta línea
roja así que lo que primero tenemos que
hacer es encontrar la ecuación de la
línea y lo podemos ver en esta
intersección con el eje y dejen de
hacerlo en un color más oscuro esta es
la intersección con el eje y que es cero
coma menos dos así que si pensamos en
esta línea y si pensamos en la ecuación
de la forma igual a mx + b que es la
forma pendiente ordenada al origen
entonces tenemos que ver es menos 2 ajá
y pensemos en la pendiente ahora es esto
si nos movemos 2 unidades a la derecha
en la dirección x es decir si delta x es
igual a 2 entonces nuestro cambio en x
es positivo y es 2 cuál es nuestro
cambio en y nuestro cambio es
-1 verdad porque baja una unidad así que
la pendiente o m
m es igual a del taller sobreventa x que
es igual a menos 1 sobre 2 que es igual
a menos un medio y sólo para confirmar
esto ya lo hemos hecho en otros lados
también podríamos haber dicho bueno qué
tal si nos vamos hacia atrás en x 4
unidades es decir qué pasa si me cambio
en x o delta x es igual a menos 4
entonces del talle
sería sería 2 verdad 2 positivos y otra
vez del taller sobre delta x sería igual
a 2 sobre menos 4 que también es igual a
menos un medio esto sólo fue para
confirmar que no depende de qué tanto
nos movemos en la dirección x y nos
vamos adelante o atrás siempre vamos a
tener que la pendiente es la misma y es
menos un medio así que la ecuación de
esta línea es igual a la pendiente que
es menos un medio por x + b que es menos
2 así que esta es la ecuación de esta
línea justo de aquí
ahora la desigualdad incluye esta línea
y todo lo que está arriba de este valor
para cualquier x digamos que para x
igual a 1 esta línea nos dice bueno te
tomas el punto bueno déjame déjame poner
a x igual a 2 para para que sea más
sencillo entonces cuando x es igual a 2
este valor
nos da menos un medio por 2 que es -1 y
-2 nos da el final menos 3 pero esta
desigualdad no sólo es igual a menos 3
porque también podemos tomarnos
cualquier otro valor arriba de menos 3 y
sabemos esto porque estamos sombreando
toda esa área verdad así que la ecuación
o más bien la desigualdad que ajusta la
gráfica de de que estamos mostrando ok
sería ya mayor o igual que menos un
medio por x menos 2
esta es la desigualdad que digamos que
representa esta gráfica y cuando y bueno
esto es solo la línea pero cuando
queremos toda el área arriba de la línea
es cuando tomamos esta desigualdad